[Music]
that turns day was originally Armistice
say President Woodrow Wilson set the day
aside in 1919 to honor the troops who
served in World War one
President Eisenhower expanded the
holiday to honor all living and still
serving veterans one way that American
veterans have continued to serve has
been by being politically active by
being elected to Congress and the
presidency in the 2018 midterms nearly
200 veterans ran for federal office on
election day veterans typically say they
want to join Congress to continue to
serve the public and to help protect our
democratic norms through legislative
rather than military means it's
important to have that trends in
Congress they can bring a level of
Defense expertise invaluable for shaping
national security policies they tend to
ask more about when and how we use
military force to conduct more oversight
of the executive branch and to work to
see that the troops have the necessary
resources and training to operate
effectively and successfully having the
voice of veterans on the legislative
front lines is a substantive addition to
our national debate what do you think
veterans bring to Congress let us know
in your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI